[Music]
whoa happy please welcome
Disneyland is your land here aid that is
Walt Disney on July 17 1955 opening day
at Disneyland the success of the
Southern California Park helped launched
the modern theme park industry but the
concept of the amusement park dates back
centuries the story is detailed in the
new book the amusement park 900 years of
thrills and spills and the dreamers and
schemers who built them by steve
Silverman Don Dahler joined the author
to hear about that wild ride
[Music]
those stomach-turning drops and
heart-pounding twists and turns have
been woven into one of America's
favorite pastimes for decades so why a
book about amusement park so you just
always love them yes where most find
thrill in the dips and dives of these
rides author Steven M Silverman finds
excitement in their history how old is
this business the 12th century 11:33
Bartholomew fair in England but the
oldest one in the world today is in
Denmark and it's more than four hundred
years old
it's called Bakken and is still operate
still operating to survive an amusement
park has to keep offering something new
a sales tactic discovered early on by
the so called greatest showman PT Barnum
in the 1840s he started his first
attraction in lower Manhattan Barnum's
American Museum he really added pizazz
to a world that didn't have it and he
was a master of publicity we that we
know but also he perfected advertisement
he said I have a Fiji mermaid well it
was a dead fish and I think a monkey's
head so none and then he would go and
advertise it in the city you would see
placards for the Fiji mermaid well it
was a bare-breasted beautiful mermaid
what you got to see inside while Barnum
knew how to put spectators on an
emotional roller coaster it was
Catherine the Great who is credited for
creating the first physical one almost
60 years earlier
she's the Empress of roller coasters
really and then when the French soldiers
were over for the war of 1812 they saw
these Russian slides they're called
Russian mountains even to this day in
Europe well they took it back with him
to Paris where they got the idea of
adding wheels but it stayed in Europe it
didn't transfer over to the United
States the fella who came up with it was
a former garment manufacturer and
tinkerer named LaMarcus Thompson
Thompson built the first patented roller
coaster in the US in 1884 it was
designed after an old mine train he
introduced what was called a switchback
railroad it only went 6 miles an hour
it only went 600 feet and that was the
first and it was right here right here
is on New York City's Coney Island home
to other amusement firsts in 1829 the
beachside resort first of his kind
opened take a bite and 90 years later
Coney Island made history again with the
introduction of an American icon the hot
dogs
Nathan's is famous but it wasn't the
original Coney Island Hidalgo is Charles
Feldman who came up with the recipe but
Nathan worked for him he used to slice
his buns
Felton's hot dogs were a dime and Nathan
said I'll sell mine for a nickel and
called them famous before they were
while Coney Island is the birthplace of
the American amusement park the 1893
Chicago World's Fair brought to life the
possibilities of what a theme park could
be Chicago World's Fair honored science
and achievements in academia and
industry but for the first time a
World's Fair had a dedicated funds owned
and that was the real hit of the fair
that's what made the money for the fair
and it was seen that this could be
transferred so it was the shadow World's
Fair that launched everything everything
including a larger-than-life never seen
before ride considered to be the 8th
wonder of the world the ferris one
Chicago was enormous and it really
wasn't until a terrible storm had blown
through the fairgrounds in Chicago that
people felt it was safe enough to ride
grossing the equivalent of 20 million
dollars in today's economy the ferris
wheel made the Chicago fair a success
and created a new demand for amusement
parks across the country but the boom
was short-lived
then came the Depression everything went
to hell and after the war television
came in nobody was interested in going
to amusement parks but then came a very
clever guy who knew what to do with
television and his name was Walt Disney
and he revolutionized everything in 1955
Disneyland opened to the public only six
and a half miles away from the already
established Knott's Berry Farm
while that Park took visitors back in
to the Wild West Disneyland offered
visitors something new a glimpse into
the future it took a couple of decades
for them to really get the formula but
now amusement parks are part of our
fabric where does the industry see its
future growth the American parks are
going gangbusters especially Disney and
Universal for the first time there their
rivals universalize Harry Potter
Disney has Star Wars but also the Six
Flags parks are doing very well as is
the original Coney Island at the
reimagined Luna Park which features
thrill rides as well as an old amusement
park staple the carousel carousels have
never been the most exciting of rise but
why have we always loved them well
they're they're actually the first ride
and they all began as war games this is
how soldiers used to practice before
they went into battle in the 12th
century what's significant especially
about this one that shiny one was carved
by marcus ilion's who was considered the
Michelangelo of carousel horse Carver's
Luna parks president al example a-- says
the key to success is respecting the
parks legacy grandfathers grandmothers
you know come here with their now their
children their grandchildren and so on
and it will show you that unique moment
or the first drop when you're about to
fall I don't know close to 60 miles per
hour and then see you know their faces
the grandchildren so proud having kind
of joined the club a club that makes us
all feel like kids again it's all to
take us out of whether your reality is
grim even just a simple roller coaster
when you're at the top going down you're
not thinking about paying the mortgage
[Music]
right that was a lot of fun to watch you
have a favorite Geauga Lake it was in
Cleveland at Portage County shout out to
all the Clevelanders um it fell into
disrepair I believe it shut down in like
2008 and then it turned into six flags
at one point then Jia Golay got it back
and it no longer exists but it was like
the hangout spot when I was like 14 15
you know I love Theatre Point in
Sandusky which is still there and you
had to go in a certain order and it was
like you did the blue streak and then
once the diamond drop was an action you
do the diamond drop then you'd make your
way to the Gemini and then you'd hit the
corkscrew in the middle of there so
there's nothing like going to an
amusement park with family or friends it
really does it just takes you to
different it's fantastic